do you have some modern concerns about
the seeping in of ideology into academic
research in these social movements for
or against marxism
for or against you know uh well nobody's
for racism but you know on the topic
like anti-racism all those kinds of uh
critical race theory things and then
also on the feminism and gender studies
and all those kinds of things yeah i
mean these have always been in the
university
when people have been most adamant
in saying that science is a neutral
value-free enterprise
it's times like the 1950s when there
weren't blacks and there weren't even
women in in universities so
what i discovered was that value
neutrality or this ideology of that we
are value-free it really arose
as a defensive shield
to prevent
greater inclusion
to prevent
you know
questioning of
the priorities of science
the practice of science the nature of
science
now we're in a period now i think of a
kind of inclusive revolution where
people are realizing well
we can't have
you know universities that look too much
a certain way
there's probably going to be
in that omelette making you know there's
going to be a few uh eggs that get
broken
and
i think
people may exaggerate the extent to
which that's going at is it's definitely
real so like cancer culture all those
kinds of things i mean it's definitely
real
uh
but it's also there in a way it's also a
distraction
from
looking at
big power in a university
if
big oil is going to control
or at least influence
the direction of the sustainability
school at stanford isn't that a bigger
issue than than whether we have we can't
say certain words on campus
in other words there's
there's some very interesting and
complex
complex aspects to this
and
uh the idea that certain words should
not be said
or that certain people should not be
invited an invitation to a university is
always political i mean who do you
invite who do you not invite
much as
an admissions process is if a student is
admitted to stanford what that really
means is 96 percent
of the applicants did not get in they
were rejected they were cancelled from a
stanford move four percent are admitted
they call it an admissions committee
they should call it a rejection
committee yes when we hire someone in in
my department
at stanford we get 300 applications and
maybe we accept one
it's not a hiring committee
it's a non-hiring committee that sounds
like toxic cancer culture all these
rejections
everybody should be accepted in that
sense it's the essence of meritocracy is
that
selection is involved in any hiring
decision in any
because in a way when you were hired
into a university you were
hired to control the means of production
at least part of it
and
this part of the politics of it is
invisible to the undergraduates because
they are consumers and you're free as a
consumer to eat whatever you want
but you're not free to own the means of
production of to say what's on the menu
and that's that's where the power is you
have to ask the question where's the
power in the university i think that uh
like at mit the entire administration
should get fired regularly and and more
power put in the hands of faculty and
students
there is an overgrowth that happens that
it feels like
administrators
are more easily influenced by big
tobacco
than faculty maybe it's me being sort of
romantic about the idea of faculty but
if you're in the battle doing the
research i feel like
well i don't know
i don't know i don't know but it feels
like
the administration helps you
delude yourself
longer
so it prevents you from waking up it's
like no it's okay to take this funny oh
jeffy epstein that's okay and oh okay so
he got he went to prison let's just keep
it a little bit secret it's fine just
keep taking the money and i feel like
that comes from the administration more
than the faculty well there's certainly
a cult of celebrity
a cult of money
donors have the remember in the whole
scandal about the side door entrance uh
in in universities there's always been
the you know the front door and the back
door where the the back door is the the
rich donors the kids are the rich donors
the legacy
kids that you still get
so
there are a lot of ways universities get
corrupted they get corrupted through
money they get corrupted through
influence
and
that should be recognized
you